i'm not superstitious but
i'm i am a little stitious
i am on the two kids sleep schedule so
i'm up and at them at 4 15
but no kids so i honestly didn't know
what to do with myself
and then i thought of something uh
years dwight what the
oh man what do you think happened
ah looks like jim got mixed up with some
bad apples
oh no no no no
it wasn't me
we gotta find the wanda at that alcohol
club oh
god
when i was a boy
there was an empty house
just up the hill from my families it was
rumored a man committed suicide there
after being possessed by the devil
one day a young woman lydia
moved into the house with her infant
child that very night lydia was awakened
by a loud
heinous hissing sound
she walked to the nursery and there in
baby's crib was a snake
wrapped around baby's neck
squeezing tighter and tighter oh my
goodness the crib was full of dirt
babies struggled to free itself from
underneath reaching and clawing gasping
for air
embalmed bodies rose from their
sarcophagi
lurching toward baby
for they were mummies no
amongst them was a man
tall
slim jim
almost instinctively she turned to her
husband oh wait she thought
i don't have a husband
for lydia and her husband had had an
argument
one they couldn't get past each night
they slept one inch farther apart until
one night lydia left
it was about this time she lost herself
in imaginary worlds
she had quit the book club the choir
citing something about their high
expectations
her lips slowly grew together from
disuse every time she wanted to act and
didn't another part of her face hardened
until it was stone
and that fevered night
she rushed to the nursery and threw open
the door
baby are you okay
baby sat up slowly
turned to mother
and said
i'm fine [ __ ]
i'm fine
okay you know what
everybody
let's just get over the whole meredith
thing she cracked her pelvis a tiny
little crack and she's gonna be fine so
let's just
michael angela's cat died
sprinkles
oh
i'm sorry angela man what a day huh
how could it get any worse the computer
crashes with the porn and then meredith
with the accident and then
pringles
god
that's three things i'll tell you what's
going on
this office is cursed
and we need to do something about it why
i'm taking responsibility
and it is up to me
to get rid of the curse
that hit meredith with my
car i'm not superstitious but
i'm i am a little stitious
okay
um okay
everybody
be prepared
to be scared
okay
[Music]
the cinema of the unsettling is a
growing film movement
the most well-known film in the genre is
an hour-long shot of a squirrel with
diarrhea
[Music]
is that my grandmother
what's the story there is no story yeah
it seems like there isn't a narrative
maybe the filmmaker realized that even
narrative is comforting
[Music]
what the hell is going on here okay i
think we've seen enough but you can turn
it off now
yeah kill it
go ahead turn it on thank you did you
get in my car so just to be safe they
are giving her the rabies vaccine oh
god rabies
i was in the hospital room with her
how contagious is that is that like an
std here no you've got to be bitten by
something this place is so cursed
actually the doctor said it was lucky
she came into the hospital because the
only way to beat rabies is to start
treatment before the symptoms set in
lockjaw
i know a lot of you are very upset with
me for endangering meredith's life by
hitting her
with my car
but it may make you feel a little bit
better to know that before that happened
dwight endangered her life
by putting a garbage bag over her head
that had a bat in it
six of one really turns out meredith has
been exposed to rabies which is like 10
times worse than a little crack in your
pelvis thanks to me she went to the
hospital and i saved her life
curse is broken
curse is broken people
welcome children of the scranton
industrial park community
[Music]
join your gangster pumpkin
on his pallet truck of doom don't worry
about a thing
rest assured you'll see me later
[Music]
we are doing a haunted house this
halloween
which is actually kind of spooky because
as legend has it on this very site there
used to be a productive paper company
i am going to scare these kids so bad
this is the spookiest warehouse in the
world
kids
you don't believe me
just take a look
whoa
scary huh this is a surgery with
an octopus and a burn victim black widow
lilu from the fifth element look nobody
told me what people were all right
so label yourselves or take what you get
i want to sell your blood it's really
not the trend of vampires right now here
is an old man and a golf dude and then
the old crone from drag me to hell i'm a
hobo i asked for a list
and a clown
i'm jigsaw idiot you're not as scary as
a bookface over there
yes i am the popular social networking
site known as bookface
okay kids you all have been so good and
unbelievably patient
so i think you are gonna get some candy
[Applause]
kids just remember
suicide is never the answer all right
why is christmas the only holiday that
can have a message
it is the easy way out you are not alone
what the hell is wrong with you
who wants candy
you